[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de france 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y los acompaño en
este programa esta vez para analizar los
cambios de la guerra de ucrania las
fuerzas locales han recuperado más
terreno al continuar su contraofensiva
en el este del país rusia por su parte
ha reforzado sus ataques aéreos en
algunas de las zonas reconquistadas en
los últimos días miles de tropas rusas
se han visto obligadas a retirarse de
varias ciudades clave del sur y del
noreste y el presidente de volodymyr
selenski dice que son hasta 6.000
kilómetros cuadrados los que han sido
retomados para el análisis de estas
noticias nos acompañan cristiana medina
profesor titular de la universidad de
san sebastián y también en género
beristáin profesores de política
internacional en la unam y del
tecnológico de monterrey ambos gracias
por su compañía en segundo se vuelvo con
ustedes y mientras tanto a nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
hacen parte de esta conversación dejen
sus preguntas y sus comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
twitter instagram y en facebook donde no
se encuentran como france24
y también arroba angel ago efe 24 mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta ese numeral
el debate efe 24 en youtube además
pueden seguir nuestra señal en streaming
saludamos también a las personas que nos
están escuchando en nuestro podcast no
olviden que todos los contenidos de este
programa están disponibles en app el
podcast en spotify deezer y en junín
antes de iniciar con el análisis vamos a
ver cómo sienten los ciudadanos los
cambios que se están produciendo en el
terreno ucraniano
una contraofensiva relámpago que está
cambiando el rumbo de la guerra y
amplias sonrisas en estos soldados
ucranianos que son aclamados como héroes
en las ciudades y pueblos liberados
sentimos la misma emoción cuando
liberamos la región de schumi cuando te
encuentras con residentes felices que te
dicen por fin estás aquí es muy emotivo
tras los rápidos avances ucranianos la
retirada rusa queda al descubierto desde
tanques con la letra zeta a los equipos
de comunicación y lo más importante las
reservas de munición
vamos a enviar toda esta munición a los
rusos como un pequeño regalo nos hace
felices poder hacerlo en las primeras
horas en la ciudad de acción el humo
sigue saliendo de los edificios signos
de varios días de intensos combates la
ciudad había servido como base
estratégica de reabastecimiento para el
ejército ruso pero hoy la bandera azul y
amarilla vuelve a ondear entre las
ruinas
es decir que estoy feliz es un eufemismo
ni siquiera tengo palabras para expresar
lo
teníamos lágrimas en los ojos llevamos
seis meses esperando a nuestros soldados
no pensábamos que llegarían tan rápido y
estamos muy contentos
moscú había expresado su retirada como
una reagrupación planeada de antemano
pero las emisiones de la televisión
estatal durante el fin de semana
cambiaron el tono admitiendo que había
abandonado su principal bastión en el
noreste a pesar del revés el ejército
ruso dijo que bombardeo zonas retomadas
por ucrania no lejos de jarquín
regresó entonces para hablar del tema de
ucrania y nos acompaña en christian
medina el profesor de titular de la
universidad de san sebastián y también
género beristáin y profesores de
política internacional en la unam a
ambos gracias y comienzo con cristian
entre 4.000 y 6.000 kilómetros cuadrados
fueron recuperados de rusia esto según
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski sin embargo estas cifras habría
que revisarlas y lo haremos más adelante
qué tan representativos son estos
números
bueno yo creo que en toda guerra de
largo aliento como ésta siempre van a
ver ganadas y perdidas ofensivas y
contraofensivas y probablemente a 200
días desatado el conflicto se siente y
al desgaste baja la moral por cierto y
también se está notando la presencia del
apoyo que le ha dado occidente al
presidente es el es que ya el pueblo
ucraniano en 200 días hemos podido ver
que ya hay una capacitación en el
momento que han recibido también 200 ya
no hemos sido capaces de ver también
como la moral del pueblo ucraniano que
ha sido levantado a la guerra en masa ha
permitido que este pueblo finalmente
haya tenido las herramientas necesarias
para enfrentar a un enemigo como el
ejército ruso que yo diría que el
ejército ruso no ha mandado a las
mejores tropas tampoco ha sido una una
avanzada donde se haya desplegado la
mayor cantidad de armamento o tecnología
porque no nos olvidemos que siempre esto
ha sido entendido no como una guerra
recién hoy día aparece en mucho el
debate de que hay que poner el nombre de
guerra siempre fue entendido como una
operación especial en esas condiciones
evidentemente la restricción al tanto de
armamento como de tropas está bastante
más restringida
claro de todas maneras hay que hacer la
aclaración para nuestros televidentes
que es rusia el país que denomina esto
como una operación especial ante la
comunidad internacional
occidentales esto es una guerra y una
invasión a ucrania gracias profesor y
ahora quisiera ir con el género
beristáin para la misma pregunta cuatro
mil y seis mil kilómetros cuadrados que
podrían haber sido retomados y van
actualizando las cifras de día a día que
representan para ustedes estas cifras de
género
también considero que puede deberse a un
posible desgaste de las tropas rusas han
estado en el teatro de operaciones por
200 días pero debemos de considerar que
no se ha visto el grueso del ejército
ruso en operación
cabe destacar que pues la ayuda a nivel
internacional a la ayuda que ha
promovido los estados de la otan y de la
unión europea parecen estar rindiendo
frutos pero ya se anunció que tanto irán
como corea del norte están dispuestos a
ayudar a arroz en su esfuerzo bélico
corea del norte ofreció la utilización
de 100.000 tropas y el perdón airam está
ofreciendo drones para que los rusos
puedan recuperar terreno entonces creo
que todavía está muy lejos de poder
anunciar que ucrania va a poder expulsar
a los rusos de su territorio al menos
quizá por otros 200 días generó y se
cree que éste está en eventual entrada
de corea del norte y de irán para apoyar
al lado ruso podría causar efectos la
guerra y no hablemos pues de los efectos
económicos y de sanciones
sí por supuesto va a traer efectos
secundarios bastante importantes cabe
resaltar que pues la ayuda internacional
que le está ofreciendo los estados de la
otan y algunos estados europeos a
ucrania pues no es ayuda gratuita o en
algún momento en ucrania va a tener que
pagar esa ayuda tanto económica como
militar entonces ucrania enfrenta un
proceso muy complicado en el futuro de
nuevo planeaba estar destruida y sobre
todo endeudada con sus aliados por otro
lado si llegasen a entrar tropas
norcoreanas efectivas en el terreno de
operaciones estas tropas si están
altamente capacitadas y tienen muy
buenos manejos en cuanto a este cohetes
de armas ofensivas de alto alcance
mientras que las tropas ucranianas han
estado teniendo que aprender al vapor y
al calor de la de las operaciones del
teatro de guerra entonces puede haber
una decantación sustancial si es que
moscú aceptan la ayuda de corea del
norte pero sobre todo la comunidad
internacional se verá bastante
mi hermano bastante quiero utilizar la
palabra correcta quizá este sea bastante
desgastada ante esta posibilidad
y cristian a usted cómo evalúa el hecho
de que otro país que es potencialmente
considerado un país en nuclear pudiera
tener un ingreso en la guerra no hace
muchos días corea del norte oficial hizo
una nueva ley en la que establece que
deben ser reconocidos como un estado
nuclear y que la desnuclearización
además no es una opción
bueno yo creo que evidentemente el tener
a este actor invitado a este conflicto
tan trágico supone un momento de tensión
muy álgido en las relaciones
internacionales sería absurdo pensar que
eeuu va a mirar para el lado y no va a
tener alguna injerencia directa si un
estado como el que acabamos de nombrar
participa un conflicto en el fondo jamás
un conflicto del cual no llevaba parte
sino que simplemente lo está haciendo
para alguna medida estratégica o saca
algún tipo de beneficio y quisiera crear
otro tema que complemente un poco la
opinión de mi ilustre colega quedan
todavía los meses más duros de un
conflicto como es el invierno en una
mirada histórica recordemos lo que
significó en invierno durísimo cuando
hitler tratos no es cierto de ocupar
moscú-rusia unión soviética en aquel
momento entonces también hay que tener
cuenta que si las tropas están
preparadas precisamente para enfrentar
al famoso general invierno que ha
diezmado a más de alguna tropa desde la
época de napoleón ahora volviendo a la
consulta original eeuu no va a quedar
absolutamente ajeno al debate si corea
del norte se involucra directamente con
tropas y hace un despliegue en
territorio que no es el propio sino es
el territorio de ucrania porque ahí
evidentemente la otan y la ayuda de una
europea y por supuesto también lo que
podría significar una eventual reunión
de emergencia en el consejo de seguridad
seguramente el curso la guerra podría
perfectamente tomar un cariz un poco más
trágico y con mayor peligro para el
destino de occidente bien cristian ya
que usted pone precisamente está el tema
ucrania dijo el martes este martes que
temía que rusia intensificar a los
ataques a sus sistemas de energía para
dificultar la supervivencia de kiev e en
este invierno que ya se avecina y pues
que estaba pidiendo en ese sentido más
ayuda a los aliados occidentales más
ayuda de militar y eeuu ya respondió
diciendo que probablemente en los
próximos días anunciará una vez más otro
paquete de ayuda para ucrania
primero pues que nuevos elementos de
ayuda militar necesitan y qué pasaría en
el escenario de que se vieran gravemente
o más afectadas las redes de energía que
ya han sido constantemente atacadas
bueno evidentemente que el corte de
suministro eléctrico supone un golpe
durísimo a la línea de flotación de una
sociedad que finalmente en el invierno
por las características que tiene es
durísimo y obviamente supone también
someterlo a una atención en este sentido
térmica brutal
ya hay preocupación en la europa
occidental por los cortes suministro que
van a sufrir probablemente en este
invierno
estamos hablando de condiciones que
muchas veces requieren una calefacción
permanente para poder funcionar en todos
los niveles y por otro lado el tema de
la ayuda militar norteamericana que
nuevamente se intensifica es porque hay
que renovar los equipos hay que seguir
teniendo adiestramiento hay que
obviamente preparar mucho más gente y
este encentro cualquier ayuda económica
que para más permita también darle a una
sociedad devastada del punto de vista
productivo alimentación y continuar
también con un con tal vez con las
peores víctimas de cualquier guerra que
son los inocentes los niños y las
mujeres para que ellos dentro de todo
este concepto de lo que significa la
guerra puedan todavía tener algún tipo
de educación todavía en mirar con
optimismo el futuro eso también
significa en la ayuda económica logramos
ayuda económica no es solamente el
armamento es también ayuda humanitaria
que es vital para poder mantenernos a la
llamada esperanza de que en algún futuro
ojalá y esperar muy próximo este
conflicto llega al final bueno y sobre
esos ayudas precisamente el presidente
de volodymyr selenski anunció que iba a
reinstaurar los pagos pensionales a los
adultos mayores en ucrania en un
esfuerzo que pues por supuesto tiene que
venir financiado de alguna parte ahora
hablando de lo que está pasando y de
esta contraofensiva ucraniana que dice
que está recuperando amplias o de
cantidades de terreno se habla de seis
mil kilómetros cuadrados que fueron
recuperados por ucrania y cuatro mil que
están totalmente controlados hasta el
momento en este sentido los funcionarios
ucranianos han dicho que es importante
hacer una distinción entre lo que es
tomar territorio y lo que es garantizar
que ese territorio está completamente
asegurado cuál es entonces el escenario
de avance ustedes como ven este cambio
de rumbo aparente en la guerra de
ucrania y comienzo por favor con genaro
muchas gracias bueno en el teatro de
operaciones puede ir variando
sustancialmente a lo largo del tiempo en
el cual se vaya desarrollando el retomó
el factor del invierno que lo había
comentado mi contertulio
acertadamente ucrania va a tener que
esforzarse muchísimo para poder mantener
esas zonas recuperadas si es que rusia
está esperando a que el invierno pues
haga estragos no nada más en la
población ucraniana sino en las vías de
suministro y aprovisionamiento de sus
tropas en este sentido podría rusia
utilizar el invierno para quizás no
hacer frente sustancial contra las
tropas sino cortar las vías de
suministro y dejar que las tropas queden
exhaustas y queden aisladas de cualquier
esfuerzo proveniente de kiev quiero
añadir que la ayuda internacional podría
también verse afectada llegada en
invierno ya que la sociedad europea
recientemente ha estado expresando a sus
gobiernos particularmente
en españa e italia y en el reino unido
que se levanten las sanciones a rusia
porque ellos están pagando de su
bolsillo en los costos elevados del gas
y la electricidad
entonces parece ser que hay una medida
estratégica por parte de rusia para
esperarse al invierno y recuperar
nuevamente este terreno está 6.000
kilómetros cuadrados que posiblemente no
pueda defender ucrania llegaba la
temporada invernal viene y su opinión es
de cristian
mi opinión es que esto podría
transformarse una victoria pírrica que
aparentemente parece ser una ganada pero
a largo plazo finalmente la
contraofensiva rusa nuevamente puede
tomar posición de estos territorios los
rusos tan acostumbrado este tipo de
conflictos en una mirada histórica hay
innumerables ejemplos que de alguna
manera revisten este tipo de escenario
no es un escenario que ellos no que para
ello sea novedoso diferente ellos no han
vivido y lo han sufrido han resistido
que también es importante la segunda
guerra para ellos fueron casi 20
millones de muertos entonces ellos tiene
una tradición épica histórica respecto a
cómo enfrentar este tipo de conflictos
el temor es que ante la alegría un poco
anticipada de muchos medios occidentales
que hablaban de estos territorios
ganados lo importante como lo que
ustedes y al principio no sólo hay que
ocupar el territorio sino que hay que
asegurar que ese territorio no va a
volver a perderse y eso a veces es mucho
más dificultoso que simplemente la
llegada triunfal de las tropas a
cualquier terreno
entretanto para nuestros dos invitados
después putin ya respondió a esta
expulsión de tropas que asegura haber
conseguido ucrania en entre 4.000 y
6.000 kilómetros cuadrados de terreno
dijo que no es una retirada que no es un
repliegue sino una reagrupación y que
estas tropas se preparan para su
siguiente movimiento o su siguiente fase
en esta guerra
que podemos leer de esa declaración
teniendo en cuenta que lo que se ha
visto en los últimos meses es que como
decía uno de nuestros invitados al
inicio las tropas que están desplegadas
en ucrania no son necesariamente las más
capacitadas que género
muchas gracias nuevamente por la
pregunta yo creo que vladimir putin
tiene muy medida la situación él fue
militar por supuesto tuvo mejor
preparación que su contraparte salines
que perdón y en este sentido yo creo que
putin tiene muchísimo todavía que de
dónde sacaron tropas frescas y armamento
mucho más poderoso que utilizar ahora
bien creo que es muy peligroso tratar de
acorralar a putin y creo que él es un
líder que no dudaría mucho en escalar el
conflicto a utilizar armas de mucha
mayor capacidad y sobre todo armas de
destrucción masiva entonces sí hay que
tener mucho cuidado con este y tratar de
arrinconar a rusia y tratar de
arrinconar a putin creo que aun todavía
veremos mucho el esfuerzo de los rusos
ellos resistieron ocho años en
afganistán y la primera guerra de
chechenia fueron un tomás años entonces
todavía no se ha visto el grueso del
poder y el músculo que tendría en este
momento rusia no entonces si si debemos
tomar en cuenta las palabras tomaron muy
en serio vladimir putin porque no él no
tendría hincapié o no tendría este
miramientos para seguir escalando el
conflicto bueno género y porque no se ha
visto todavía este músculo de vladimir
putin que lo detiene para desplegarse
con más fuerza y finalmente lograr lo
que lo que se cree que él crea desde el
principio y era una guerra rápida una
invasión rápida y apoderarse del
territorio muy velozmente y poder salir
de ucrania mientras tanto la verdad es
que está invirtiendo todavía más y más
capital político con cada día que pasa
de la guerra
bueno creo que se debe básicamente que
la guerra cuesta cuesta mucho dinero y
las sanciones económicas que ha impuesto
a los países de europa y los países de
la otan han hecho mella sustancial en la
economía rusa entonces lo que
necesitaría en este momento vladimir
putin es que sus aliados tanto china
como la india e irán continúen comprando
este petróleo bueno en este caso árabe
saudí que no aumenta su producción
petrolera para que los costos del barril
de petróleo sigan a la alza y de esa
manera pues pueda financiar vladimir
putin la guerra movilizar una mayor
cantidad de tropas pues requiere de
mucho esfuerzo económico y es quizá este
pulsamos en este punto en el cual no
tiene los recursos suficientes putin
para poder desplegar una mayor cantidad
de efectivos sobre el terreno bueno
cristian y la misma pregunta para usted'
que tanto puede seguir invirtiendo rusia
en la invasión está preparado el país de
vladimir putin para continuar una
ofensiva que no da muestras de terminar
pronto y que esperábamos q que fuera una
invasión rápida de entrada por salida
yo considero que los principales costos
son el relajamiento interno de la
lealtad que se tenía a putin y el costo
político se está viendo se está notando
el líder checheno que es un líder muy
importante ha hecho un diagnóstico muy
negativo respecto a los temas
estratégicos ha criticado fuertemente el
alto mando de las tropas rusas por una
serie de equivocaciones y desaguisado
con respecto a esto también al interior
de la sociedad rusa se están haciendo
una serie de elementos de represión de
multas de juicio respecto a aquellos que
opinen en forma negativa del conflicto
entonces hay una revuelta interna dentro
de una sociedad que a pesar de la
tecnología actual es muy hermética y
cuando a winston churchill siempre
preguntaban qué es lo que era para el
rusia decía que siempre para él cuando
veía el mapa ruso veía un acertijo
dentro de un misterio envuelto un enigma
entonces la información que también
nosotros tenemos de lo que está
ocurriendo dentro de rusia tampoco es la
totalidad
recordemos que en el caso de presidente
putin además había cerrado todos los
archivos históricos ah eso es el nivel
de control total de la información que
se tiene respecto al interior de la vida
cotidiana del mundo ruso la vida
política también y ya ahí hay voces
disidentes y a ningún presidente le
gusta que cuando hay que mostrar un
frente de cohesión unido frente a un
conflicto externo hayan poses disidentes
que no sólo son de la oposición sino que
también son del sector es ultra
nacionalista entonces de alguna manera
también creo que ahí el capital que él
puede perder es muchísimo ahora una
advertencia respecto a eso no sabemos
realmente si él es el más radical de las
posturas respecto a la guerra de ucrania
probablemente al interior es un círculo
mucho más cerrado y mucho más hermético
hay tal vez personas que son mucho más
termo cefálica y mucho más radical en
respecto a lo que hay que hacer con con
ucrania entonces también ahí hay que
tener un poco de prudencia respecto a
que sacamos a pu timón y ya que
imponemos a porque probablemente sea el
remedio que la enfermedad
bueno entre tanto siguiendo un poco con
la línea de lo que usted nos cuenta
cristian a algunos concejales rusos se
dice que habrían pedido la renuncia de
putin esto a nivel interno esto no son
noticias digamos oficiales que llegan
pero además recordando el caso de daria
dubina la hija de uno de los grandes
digamos estrategas y pensadores rusos
que fue asesinada también empezaron a
llegar noticias de medios
internacionales en las que se insinuaba
que la muerte de duggan a no fue un
asesinato causado ni por occidente ni
por ucrania sino que fue un atentado
interno para desestabilizar o para
mostrar desacuerdo con putin después por
una guerra que en lo práctico no avanza
como se esperaba usted qué opina de este
tipo de eventos que aunque no están
confirmados pues si podrían dar un
mensaje amplio de lo que se está
viviendo al interior de rusia
bueno yo en lo personal pienso que a
veces occidente ppk de ingeniería en el
sentido de pensar que los que son
contrarios a putin o un poco más próxima
en tales son realmente occidentales
atlantistas y cuando en realidad son
occidentales pero eurosocialistas es
decir miran mucho más hacia el centro de
gràcia que al mundo occidental entonces
es un error muchas veces que se comete y
evidentemente que esos sectores que son
se ubican en esa línea no reconocen
realmente una cercanía vital con el
mundo occidental sino que más bien con
esa zona del centro de eurasia todo este
tipo de atentados que se están
cometiendo y que además son propios
también una época que pensamos que
habíamos dejado atrás como la guerra
fría porque usted nombra este trágico
evento luctuoso pero también estaba el
envenenamiento que se hacía en forma
selectiva a algunos opositores a sus
prácticas que uno pensó que estaban
exorcizada de la vida política
internacional porque nos recordaban la
época de la calle y sin embargo todavía
vemos que sigue vigente este tipo de
cuestión evidentemente generan tensión
pero además también son la advertencia
para todos nosotros que también tiene
una voz disidente
a lo que está ocurriendo hoy día dentro
de lo que son los muros del camino bueno
hasta hace aproximadamente un mes o tal
vez poco más las noticias que nos
estaban llegando desde ucrania eran
respecto de la toma rusa y girando
alrededor de las ciudades y territorios
con los que rusa russia se había hecho
durante la guerra porque porque este
cambio que rusia no pudo anticipar qué
pasó para que moscú no pudiera prever o
más bien responder a este revés género
bueno creo que ahí tendríamos que tratar
de entender cuál fue la reacción de la
sociedad ucraniana creo que hubo una
mala lectura por parte de las
autoridades del kremlin que pensaron que
pues iban a recibir a las tropas rusas y
que muchos ucranianos estaban cansados
del gobierno de selene es que qué bueno
sí estaban muy cansados de él por los
actos de corrupción que se giraban en
torno a su gobierno pero en el discurso
que tiene vladimir putin o queda
vladimir putin al inicio de la operación
militar él les llama tovar ex no
camaradas en un intento por hacerles ver
que ellos están llegando ahí para
liberar del gobierno corrupto de
zelinski y que ese gobierno los estaban
enfrentando a sus amigos e incluso
parientes porque habrá muchos ucranianos
que tengan familiares en rusia hay
muchos rusos que tengan familiares en
ucrania entonces creo que fue una
lectura equivocada
y que la sociedad ucraniana se juntó se
agrupó en torno a su presidente y
dijeron pues será muy corrupto pero es
el presidente que tenemos y todo es en
torno a este presidente lo que hicieron
fue pues esforzarse para evitar la
ocupación rusa y entonces de ahí que no
pudiéramos hablar de una ofensiva de
este tipo big creek porque los
ucranianos no respondieron como
pensaron en algún momento las
autoridades de tren y es por eso que
hemos visto en las noticias cómo reciben
a sus soldados con mucha alegría después
de haber desocupado el ejército ruso
ciertas regiones pero pues tendremos que
esperar todavía un poquito más para
poder ver un desenlace pronto y expedito
en esta guerra que apunta a que va a ir
todavía un poquito más lejos viene
alemania de que más bien jugando un
papel de tímido bajo el mandato de sol
se durante la guerra se comunicó con
vladimir putin e a conversaron estos dos
líderes y nuevamente soul se puede ser
la publicación que nos llega es que ha
pedido otra vez una salida negociada del
retiro de las tropas lo que se ha pedido
desde el inicio de esta invasión a
ucrania qué papel está cumpliendo en
este momento europa en el avance de la
guerra más allá de estas sanciones que
hemos visto que han sido poco efectivas
o no lo suficientemente efectivas para
frenar las actividades bélicas en el
territorio ucraniano
en mi caso particular pienso que la
salida negociada tiene que darse en
términos de igualdad no se negocia
cuando tienes a un enemigo que está de
rodillas y creo que el avance que hemos
visto estos días permite que un gran se
levante con un alto no de igualdad
frente a una posible eventualidad
negociación con moscú por otro lado los
europeos necesitan una ucrania
digamos robusta no intervenida no un
estado títere porque finalmente es el
único cordón el único espacio que tienen
entre la frontera de rusia con la europa
occidental entonces hay también el hecho
de que se transforma en un pivote
geopolítico muy estratégico también para
que europa vive también con tranquilidad
que no va a tener que soportar en algún
día una invasión o una crispación de
situaciones bélicas como la que está
viendo hoy día el mundo género que
podemos hacernos como idea de esta
llamada entre chelsea y vladimir putin
hasta hace no mucho era en manuel más
krone que constantemente estaba dando
reportes sobre sus comunicaciones con
rusia
bueno creo que las sanciones que le
impusieron a rusia ya están teniendo un
efecto búmeran hacia la sociedad alemana
la sociedad alemana es la que más
depende del gas en el ruso y entonces es
importante mencionar que en este momento
el sol se encuentra entre la espada y la
pared por un lado tiene la presión de
eeuu para que continúe con las sanciones
y por otro lado tiene la presión de sus
ciudadanos de que están pagando los
costos económicos de
las sanciones no finalmente se acerca
nuevamente
digamos repetimos la situación del
invierno y entonces los los alemanes se
están viendo con preocupación qué es lo
que van a hacer si es que no se van a
poder recibir gas ruso durante este
invierno ahora yo quisiera resaltar el
hecho de que turquía está jugando un
mejor papel como mediador que los
europeos en este sentido fue fueron los
turcos quienes lograron la negociación
para que ucrania pudiera sacar barcos
cargados de granos
y esto pues llegará a los mercados
internacionales y que abatieran las
posibles hambrunas que se estaban
produciendo en áfrica y el oriente medio
en estas y esta situación creo que no ha
habido mucha respuesta de parte de
vladimir putin hacia sus homólogos
europeos precisamente por las sanciones
entonces
vladimir putin no va a retirarse de
ucrania hasta que no le garanticen por
escrito esta vez que ucrania nunca va a
formar parte de la otan y que nunca va a
ser aceptada en la unión europea y entre
tanto quisiera preguntarles también por
la situación 9 que transcurre en el
donbass es donde se concentra el poder
ruso ucrania promete que va a recuperar
este territorio pero esto es para usted
es factible en este momento y cómo están
las cosas
cristian
operaciones tan dinámico como que
estamos viendo en la medida en que el
teatro de operaciones cambia
radicalmente aumentan las ayudas
probablemente hay un control en algún
momento pero creo que el alquiler lo
relevante es que ese control tiene que
ser asegurado como decíamos hace un
momento atrás no basta sólo con entrar
al territorio hay que darle una garantía
de seguridad permanente y ahí yo creo
que hay un punto débil porque eso es una
zona que desde los inicios del conflicto
ha sido muy apetecida y muy resguardada
desde moscú entonces no veo a mediano
plazo ni a largo plazo que moscú
simplemente se deshaga de una zona que
realmente considera que es un pivote
importante para su
tranquilidad geopolítica pensando como
decía no cierto mi ilustre colega de que
el gran temor que hay en el kremlin es
que buscan ya intenté nuevamente esos
deseos que siempre expresados en ser
parte de la otan y ser parte de la unión
europea genaro como ve usted la
situación en el donbass
bueno no debemos de perder de vista que
la mayor parte de la población en el
donbass es rusófona y étnicamente rusa y
entonces aunque se retiren las tropas
rusas las tropas de moscú ellos
continuarán presentando resistencia a
las tropas ucranianas cabe resaltar que
ellos han estado en conflicto con
ucrania desde el 2014 entonces
posiblemente sean estas tropas de
resistencia del donbass las que planten
digamos el plantel en la resistencia
hasta que retomen las actividades o
retomen la ofensiva del ejército ruso no
creo que ucrania pueda expulsar al
ejército ruso y controlar al cien por
ciento de esta región siempre tendrá que
habrá grupos que se opongan a la
ocupación ucraniana debido a que pues no
son ni ucranianos son únicamente rusos y
que ellos ya han saboreado la idea de
pertenecer o ser nuevamente parte de
rusia no en su momento fueron parte de
la unión soviética
y tan de estar pensando en que no van a
retroceder para poder formar parte de
rusia y ya cuando nos vamos acercando al
final de cristian que quería preguntarle
usted también acerca de las situaciones
de las filas en esta guerra
recientemente hemos informado que rusia
ha estado esforzándose por encontrar de
cualquier manera posible y a cualquier
costo nuevos reclutas que vayan a ser
desplegados en ucrania esto es una
muestra de las bajas como están en las
giras en cada lado
pues no son una muestra de las vascas
diría yo sino que además el hecho de que
el tradicional soldado ruso que tenía
toda una ética que respondía a una
tradición histórica se ha ido
desdibujando y además otro elemento que
habría que añadir que ha costado mucho
explicar dentro del propio mundo ruso el
sentido final de la guerra
recordemos que al principio se dijo que
era para sacar un gobierno nazi fascista
ultranacionalista que finalmente en los
hechos concretos no era tan entonces
obviamente que la guerra se hace muy
impopular hay un costo muy importante el
punto de vista anímico hay una serie de
desaguisados a abiertos errores esto
está costando vidas además de jóvenes
hay una generación completa que
probablemente perezca en esta guerra y
no hay ningún centro real de profundidad
no se está peleando por la grandeza de
rusia como los se hizo al antaño
entonces no es una guerra patriótica por
así decirlo sino que de alguna manera
responde a ciertos caprichos propios del
dictador de turno entonces ahí me parece
que en la sociedad rusa que ya se había
ido occidentalizando un poco que tenía
un poquito más de contacto con el mundo
de la europa desde la europa occidental
no no le encuentra sentido ir a morir a
un campo por cierto lo 2o o con nieve
por una situación que esperaría no la
entienden de buena manera y lo lo
terrible de esto es que si pasamos de
una operación especial como se denomina
el mundo ruso a una guerra total
declarada significa que la sociedad en
masa
a parte y se asumen el conflicto y eso
significa no es cierto reclutamiento
obligatorio para ir al frente de batalla
que por el momento no ha sucedido y
bueno cualquier cosa puede cambiar como
ustedes bien han dicho ya para sus
conclusiones estamos presenciando un
cambio de rumbo en la guerra esta es la
última respuesta era enero
pues es estrictamente si podría ser un
cambio de rumbo con la salvedad de que
puede cambiar en cualquier otro momento
o sea podemos ver en este momento que
ucrania avanza pero en dos semanas o
quizás tres semanas o debe ver un nuevo
cambio y que las tropas rusas vuelvan a
retomar el control de lo que hasta el
momento han perdido entonces si hay un
nuevo rumbo pero quizá este rumbo esté
todavía a punto de cambiar cabe señalar
que va a ser muy importante para
sostener este esfuerzo bélico el apoyo
internacional que pueda recibir ucrania
y el apoyo internacional no va a ser
eterno se va a llegar a un punto en que
los países que en este momento se han
decantado en favor de ucrania le tengan
que decir que hasta aquí no hasta aquí
ha llegado el apoyo y que en ese momento
pues ucrania tendrá que vérselas por sí
misma viene y cristian rápidamente sus
conclusiones
bueno me sumo a las palabras de género y
agregaría un elemento más creo que en el
mundo occidental ya no es sostenible una
guerra de largo aliento de este tipo
porque de alguna de los propios países
tienen sus propios problemas internos es
una guerra que al interior de muchos
países europeos como señaló genaro ha
generado un gran debate y no siempre es
positivo para los gobiernos porque está
afectando el bolsillo de las personas y
ahora que viene el invierno va a afectar
también la calefacción y la manera de
sobrevivir a lo que se vienen los
próximos tres meses el ámbito de la
europa occidental por lo tanto las
ayudas iniciales probablemente de alguna
manera también han ido repercutiendo en
la sociedad civil que ve que no le
encuentra salido a esto y es mejor
preocuparse los problemas internos que
involucrarse los grandes debates
internacionales especialmente de este
tipo de guerra bien pero aquí estaremos
nosotros hoy para continuar informando
acerca de los aconteceres de la guerra
en ucrania como lo hemos hecho desde el
primer día en france24 un agradecimiento
para ustedes eran cristiana y medina
profesor titular de la universidad de
san sebastián y genaro beristáin
profesor de política internacional en la
una a nuestros televidentes que sigan
con nosotros volvemos próximamente con
el debate
[Música]